(upbeat music)
(screams)
- Go big or go home, right?
- I literally get hives
every time you say that.
- It's not a dream, it's reality.
- This is a special chicken,
this is a magical chicken.
- Come on.
(screams)
- We're bringing back the Glee club.
- You two have just entered Thunder dome.
You will beg for death.
- Here, get out of the booth,
take all your clothes off
and fold yourself twelve times.
- You got it.
- Six folds huh?
What do you guys got me in a series 9000?
You cheap insect (beep) didn't think
I was worth your best equipment?
(glass breaks)
- Jesus!
- Not quite.
- This is not who you are.
- I'm the devil.
- Friends, family, dog.
- I just wanna be married again.
- And I just want a million dollars.
- So how much do you think
I can get for my kidney?
- What are you doing here?
I thought tonight was your
big anniversary dinner.
- Yeah a little change of plans.
We're gonna break up instead.
- If you're watching this
then I'm not around anymore
but don't spiral, don't
obsess, keep going.
I thought I'd leave you a little guide
to life without me.
You're lovely but you're
absolutely useless.
You know how grumpy you get
when things don't go your way.
But you got such a good
heart, you're born like it.
You just decent.
- It's just gone.
Everything we said, everything we did.
I feel like I've been erased.
- Let's not over complicate
matters unnecessarily.
- My name is Elizabeth.
- Long live Queen Elizabeth.
- Be firm, just lay down the law.
I know he's Winston Churchill and all that
but remember who you are,
you're the queen of England.
- The crown must always win.
- It's okay mom it's okay
the bullets can't get through
the armor griding
Mom I need to get you to safety.
Mom this is what I do, trust me.
- We're not kids anymore.
I mean what did you think?
We're just gonna sit
in my basement all day,
play games for the rest of our lives?
- It is important to
me that you feel safe,
like this can still be your home.
- What do we do when we reach
the place where we don't know what to do?
- We're gonna get each other through this.
- Don't focus on what you can't fix.
Focus on what you can.
- What is it you really want?
- Ice cream.
And Justice.
- Is my mom here?
- It's just us.
You and us.
- Guilty.
- I can't believe it's like this.
- Whatever way they ever do us.
- You wanna cook Crystal meth?
You know the business
- And I know the chemistry.
- Let's start with some tough love.
You two suck at pedaling meth.
- Secretary you need
to put the phone down.
- Mike, what the hell's going on?
- I said put the phone down!
- Capital's been attacked.
- Sir you are now the
president of the United States.
- Maybe you wanna calm down
before you go in there.
- I'm calm
I am tired of you people always telling me
my hands are tied.
- You feel you need to kill somebody.
- You don't get to make that call.
- I've been making that
call since you know me.
- Everything I've lost is because of you.
My home, my family, my life.
- You are a good kid.
You got manipulated by a mobster.
- But you do not deserve
to be framed for murder.
- We'll be going behind enemy lines,
outnumbered, open to
attack from all directions
and risking another gang war.
- It's unclear what
exactly caused the events
Maybe we can save them.
- Did I bend this war between us?
- We are out of our league.
- We don't get to decide
who lives and who dies.
- We're getting out and everyone of you
is crucial to that plan.
When those lights go black,
we're gonna disappear from
this place light ghosts.
- Hey there, I'm Ashley
two, what's your name?
- Everywhere you look!
- And there's more.
Ashley eternal is dreamable.
- I'm not ready to be Saarc.
- You were born for this.
Trust yourself, God chose you.
Divine bloody right.
- Wildlife still flourishes
in astonishing numbers
in a few precious places.
We'll explore the planet's
most important habitats
and celebrate the life they still support.
- You'll spoil it.